we make way for Brandel Chamblee one of
the stars of the golf channel and their
coverage of the US Open
how would you recap yesterday if
somebody didn't see the highlights
randal atypical for the PGA Tour which
is what a US Open should be it was it
was beautiful from a fan perspective but
having participated as a player I can
tell you it's no fun at all how many
events do you think should be like this
a Urich it feels like we have one that's
pretty much guaranteed although last
year's US Open was not but we're we're
okay once a year where we see these guys
maybe break par you know I'd say two or
three times a year you know the major
championships Augusta is what it is it's
a lot of fun you know you get to slay
the dragon when you're you know watching
Augusta you get there see everybody you
know make these these great bold plays
but the US Open should be about control
the Open Championship should be about
control and the PGA Championship because
it's played in such hot weather is
typically a little softer but it two or
three times a year I think is reasonable
explain to the casual fan why this is so
difficult this course well this
particular Golf Course the greens are
almost all elevated right so if the
casual fan is not familiar with
Pinehurst all the greens are not only
elevated but they roll off on the front
and on the sides and on the back so
whatever the the real space of the green
is effectively it's it's like a third
the size okay so imagine taking those
greens putting them in a place where
it's much much firmer and much much
windier so that's what this place is the
hardest greens to hit in very firm
conditions in a very windy area links
golf typically you had a really big
greens anybody's familiar with links
golf you can probably recall how big the
greens are at st. Andrews well here
they're you know a fiftieth of the size
mm-hm and they're in a spot where it
blows so I joked last night I said
they're harder to hit than a Mariano
Rivera cut fastball and that's basically
what they are who surprised you the most
most with how badly they played
yesterday Rory Rory macro I mean the
whole group that three some of jordan
Spieth
Rory and Phil Mickelson you know you
could look at it say they shot 25 over
par but I don't think anybody thought
Spieth was gonna contend as poorly as
he's putty and I don't think anybody
thought Phil Mickelson was gonna contend
as poorly as he was driving the ball all
the way he drove it okay yesterday but
Rory you know he was a lot of people's
favorite I picked him as my favorite he
had been out here in the Hamptons for a
week he had played you know pretty darn
solid at BMW everybody said that they'd
watched him play and he was just it was
mind-boggling absolutely they'd never
seen anything like it the people they
were playing practice drills with me and
he shot a tee and you look at his last
five rounds now and the US Open and
they're 78 77 80 71 said he won so it's
pretty darn surprising to see him play
so poorly yesterday I'm a 10 right now
what would I shoot on that golf course a
lot of tequila
that's after maybe before but I like
would shoot under it you shoot on I hate
to say it but I mean there was a you
know what is it Gregory who won the he
won the British hammer he's 92 yesterday
and he said as he stood out in the
fairway and give him credit because he
came and spoke to the media after
shooting 92 and he said I stood on the
fairway and I thought well I can't miss
it
long I can't miss it short I can't miss
it left and I can't miss it right so I'm
just gonna hit it right in the middle of
the green
well that that pretty much sums up the
tour players predicament yesterday feels
like this is Dustin Johnson and then
everybody else is that being fair to the
rest of long ya know it's spot-on I mean
right now you mean he's sort of crossing
that line between being a great athlete
and being a great entertainer you know I
mean it's like you go down to him you
expect him to do something great so you
have this anticipation and then he does
it it was kind of like Tiger Woods right
now I mean he is I think they just said
on the broadcast my buddy mark Brooks
just said on the broadcast he's the one
player right now who looks like he could
he could distance himself you know he
looks like he could shoot three or four
on a par and and yet you know three or
four head of the field and then white
you know wipe everybody away on the
weekend what do you think Tiger thinks
when he sees Dustin Johnson hit it the
way he hits it I'm sure it makes him sad
I mean that you know Tiger you know all
this you know as it relates to his body
and his golf swimming he's 42 years old
so age would have gotten him by now but
he pretty much did this to himself
I mean you know he he destroyed the
greatest body in the game of golf and he
destroyed the great greatest golf swing
in the history of the game so I'm sure
he's sad you know he's it's not the
Tiger you know changed his golf swing so
much is like he barked up every single
tree and now it's like he can't even he
doesn't know where home is he can't get
back to where he once was and you can
see he's trying to he looks at Dustin
and Dustin has the most obvious physical
advantages on the tour right now well
Tiger would you used to be that person
and you know the way they've worked out
was completely different I don't know
what Dustin's doing but it's right I
don't know what Tiger did but I'm pretty
darn sure was wrong I saw the interview
with Butch Harmon and Curtis Strange
yesterday and Curtis asked about Tiger
since butch was his first main teacher
and he said you know what I think it was
I'm paraphrasing kind of like what
what's holding Tiger back here and he
said he go because Tiger still wants to
hit it as far if not farther than
everybody else and I keep saying if you
if you have the mental capacity member
he was the toughest guy mentally great
short game he could tell the best pike
all these things right why wouldn't you
just say I'm gonna beat you when I need
to beat you and that's on the green
instead of you know mine's bigger than
yours I'm gonna hit a 320 and you hit a
319 like he just he's he's gotten into
that where and I think that's been to
his detriment well I guess that's one
take you know I think butch is really
you know he's a bright guy and you know
I think that's a reasonable take you
know personally I think it's I think
it's a little different than that you
know I just think it boils down to maybe
a little bit of that but mostly in my
mind it's just technique you know if his
technique were as good as Dustin
Johnson's or as good as his technique
used to be he'd be able to swing he'd be
able to hit shots the way Dustin Johnson
the way he used to be able to hit him
his techniques just not anywhere near as
good as it used to be but he doesn't put
it in the fairway though Brandel and
dustin does well that's what I'm saying
is they he doesn't put it in the fairway
not because he's swinging hard he's not
swaying any harder at the golf ball I
promise you from a percentage standpoint
than Dustin Johnson is or henrik stenson
is he's not he's he's a smart guy Tiger
Woods is not out there flailing away
Tiger knows he needs to put a number on
the floor he's not up there just
indiscriminately swinging as hard as he
can he just can't do it because it's
technique is sabotaging him so he he's
never he's never been without a teacher
he's finally without a teacher and I
know that he's trying to swing like he
once did well it's not as simple as that
nobody can do what they once did at 42
but at Jack Nicklaus you know when Jack
Nicklaus was 40 41 42
he was the best driver of the golf ball
that ever lived
statistically ever so and that's because
they just started measuring the
statistics imagine if they had
statistics when Jack was 25 but Jack
didn't change his body and he didn't
change his golf swing so his swing
lasted Tigers hasn't lasted because he
chose to change it alright I got I got
an idea and it's it's controversial and
maybe you could use it tonight with with
rich and try to shy away from
controversy okay what if you didn't have
a cut at the US Open or the majors
because now I'm looking at this just as
marketing and if I'm a broadcast partner
TV I still want to see Phil out there
Tiger out there Jordan out there Rory
out there why do we have a cut any
majors you know I've never been asked
that question I can't say that I've ever
even thought about it but in the middle
of you asked you know I thought damn
right I don't know why we have to have a
cut they can sit around play all weekend
long clearly they can they're doing it
now great idea I'll give you credit for
that one yeah well it will will bat it
around on the set
I love it well let's see who makes the
misses the cut and then you could bring
it up with you and Frank and and enrich
I love the fact that you guys
begrudgingly went into the topic of what
would be a better story Tiger winning or
Phil winning and I thought it came off
great I just thought it was you guys
framed it well and it was interesting
but the obvious answer is is Tiger
because Tiger that would that would
resonate worldwide Phil it would
resonate with housewives in you know in
golf fans you know the strong golfing
right I was going to say you know how
many kids to still have three okay and
his wife and maybe there's ten people in
the world that might think Phil's
winning would be a bigger story than
tired
oh I wouldn't I wouldn't even be close
but you know fifty years from now people
be sitting around and they'd go wow
there's only six guys that have won the
career Grand Slam and you know
historically speaking to be unbelievable
fulfill but it'd be unbelievable for
golf if Tiger Woods came back and won
and I'm I'm still I still think this
what he's doing right now if he goes on
if he can find a way to win a major
championship I think it's a better story
than you know Benna Hogan to come back I
mean Dan Hogan didn't have to go deal
with all this existential stuff that
Tiger Woods
waitwait a Hogan almost died Brandel I
know that but Hogan didn't die in the
Bob the bones healed and when Hogan was
injured he didn't come back and have to
resurrect a golf game Hogan was playing
the best he'd ever played in his entire
life when he got injured so he when he
came back he he was informed and he
wasn't gone that long and he didn't and
I'll tell you this when when you've been
through the scandal and you know I mean
even to the scale imagine if you walked
into a room with a thousand people and
they all loved and adored you right
every single one if they didn't say a
word not a word didn't say a word you'd
feel it when you walked in you'd feel it
and if he walked into a room where
everybody was talking about you or had
thoughts about you that were not you
know over the highest order you'd feel
that to that energy I think made Tiger
Woods a big part of what he was and
I'd follow him around he first came back
2010 11 12 and people would say the most
unimaginably rude and offensive things
to Tiger all during the day they'd yell
it out now there are plenty of fans out
there that love him love them but there
are plenty of Yahoo's out there saying
horrible things to Tiger Woods as he
plays I mean it just happened we were on
a set of Bay Hill life Rome was sitting
right there he was walking right behind
our set and couple of Yahoo's said I
mean just horrendous things to him and
he gets that pretty much all day long
that's pretty hard to deal with
psychologically put all those things
together the body the technique the
psychological the scandal the chipping
hips nobody's ever come back from
anything like what Tigers trying to come
back from you ever think you'll get an
invitation to the yacht Tigers yeah I
don't think I'll be having crumpets and
tea with Tiger on the dinghy
he might invite you on to throw you over
listen I like Tiger I you know his you
know I know I'm sure he doesn't like me
but but I'm I'm a big fan you know I I
have been sitting in a chair talking
about Tiger Woods it's 2004 and I've
been talking about the greatest golfer
ever arguably one of the greatest
athletes ever who has decided to change
the golf swing that made him the
greatest player ever and change his body
I challenge anybody to sit there and
talk about that every single night
without saying it's the craziest thing
in the history of sports and it is it's
the craziest thing imagine if Michael
Jordan changed his technique after 98 or
pick any other superstar athlete who
dominated and won at a level unlike
anything anybody ever seen in sports and
they decided to change the technique
that allowed them to do it and the body
not not because they had to but be just
because they were bored and wanted to
that's the craziest thing in the history
of sports not just golf and so I had to
talk about it no you did you're just
doing your job
and Tigers right I mean look Tigers best
friends are some of the nicest people in
the world
Notah Begay Steve Stricker I mean John
Cook these are nicest guys you ever meet
in your life I love those guys they're
great guys are friends of mine
so I mean Tiger I have no doubt he's
he's a nice guy
I'm sure he is and I'm sure I'd like I
didn't doubt that he'd like me Thank You
Brandel have fun tonight we'll be
watching take care dad all right Randall
chamblee golf channel for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]